on en vient maintenant au bras de fer
qui oppose kiev et à moscou une épreuve
de taille pour parier berlin des
discussions se tiennent aujourd'hui dans
la capitale française autour de
conseillers politiques russes ukrainiens
allemands et français donc ils sont
appelés à désamorcer le conflit c'est ce
qu'on appelle le format normandie en
attendant l'ukraine se sont plus que
jamais menacés par son voisin
l'intervention militaire est redouté
avant même la tenue de cette rencontre
sergueï lavrov a mis en garde en
l'écoutent
si aucune réponse constructive n'est
apportée que l'occident poursuit son
attitude agressive moscou comme le
président poutine l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises prendra les mesures de
rétorsion nécessaire la sécurité de la
russie et de ses citoyens est une
priorité inconditionnel et elle sera
assurée en toutes circonstances
et on retrouve en direct depuis moscou
notre correspondant bonjour à vous je
lis à une colline merci d'être avec nous
julian la fermeté russe encore et
toujours affirmé une nouvelle fois par
par sergueï lavrov le chef de la
diplomatie russe qui a dénoncé
l'hystérie occidental qui prévient donc
contre toute sanction
oui et ce qui est intéressant également
de remarquer ces derniers jours c'est
qu'en fait c'est aussi une guerre de
communication une fois de plus ce qui a
un peu pris le relais en attendant
peut-être un conflit plus chaud
militairement mais en tout cas voilà les
deux camps occidental et russes semblent
un peu se renvoyer la balle désormais 2
qui alimente en réalité les sanctions
voilà on entendu sergueï lavrov à lui
s'est montré très ferme aujourd'hui une
fois de plus en voilà en menaçant les
états unis allaient l'ukraine également
d'autres répulsion très forte en cas de
menace la sécurité russes et justement
le temps également
déclaré ces derniers jours envisager
également d'envoyer des troupes
supplémentaires quelques milliers de
troupes de l'otan en plus vers son flanc
oriental et la russie de son côté a elle
est bien commencé à refaire des
exercices militaires en crimée annexée
et autour de la mer noire également
rappelons aussi que la russie a annoncé
des différents exercices militaires en
biélorussie avec son allié biélorusse
sur mois de février mais je disais au
delà de ces petits mouvements de troupes
ces petites annonces sur le plan
militaire pour l'instant et bien sûr
tous désormais une guerre de
communication qui a pris le dessus on
sent que voilà
même du côté de sergueï lavrov du
pouvoir russe on accuse vraiment
l'occident d'en faire un peu trop autour
de ce ces mouvements de troupes russes
et de participer à une sorte d'hystérie
collective en fait à l'ouest également à
kiev sur ce dossier depuis plusieurs
semaines c'est vraiment la ligne qui est
martelée par les journaux russes bon on
sait que les journaux russes sont plutôt
unanimement proche du kremlin également
les chercheur en géopolitique les
experts ici trouve qu encore une fois et
bien il n'y avait certes un certain
alarmisme un peu trop important est
peut-être une hystérie un peu trop
grande sur ces mouvements de troupes
rappelons le sur sol russe sur leur
propre territoire et encore une fois
petit exemple par rapport aux deux pas
de ça c'est les décisions apparemment de
du royaume uni l'australie de peut-être
et bien évacuer leurs diplomates de la
capitale kiev face à une menace
d'invasion russe imminente c'est encore
une fois dénoncées par la russie et par
sergueï lavrov lui-même aujourd'hui
comme de la fantasy est quelque chose
qui est beaucoup trop excessif est trop
dans l'hystérie une fois de plus donc
voilà il semblerait que la russie semble
mettre l'accent là dessus et dire
qu'encore une fois ils n'auront qu'une
aucunement l'intention de réellement
vaio l'ukraine et que tout ça c'est de
là c'est encore une fois les états unis
et le bloc occidental qui mellul sur le
feu voilà on verra peut-être ce que vous
coordonnez les discussions désormais
diplomatiques entre l'allemagne la
russie la france et l'ukraine mais il
semblerait que en tout cas côté russe
s'est peut-être côté allemand français
et ukrainiens on semble un peu plus
peut-être vous désormais vouloir
l'apaisement et poursuivre les
discussions sur ce dossier désormais
dans les prochaines heures nous diront
merci beaucoup julien de collines en
direct depuis moscou